scene said it was 1 8 of a page and it
said Costello executes man kneeling in
the marshes he he looked at that and he
goes okay I can do that but I think I
can make it better so what I do is
instead of a man kneeling in the marshes
I may get a woman but I'm not gonna be
alone I put Rey in the scene with me and
I do the thing and I shoot her in the
back of the head like it says in the
script but if you leave the camera
rolling I turn to Rey and I say geez you
feel funny now that's a really Sinister
thing to say because it means I do this
a lot and there's a way people fall now
you could end the scene there but if you
leave the camera rolling Rey steps
forward and he reveals that he's holding
an ax he's gonna chop her up now you
could end the scene there but if you
leave the camera I turned Ray and say I
think I want to [ __ ] her again and he
says but if you keep the camera rolling
Rey stops and looks at me and I go
and that's a Sinister thing to do
because we're making a joke out of this
whole thing